all right I'm gonna be talking
about I think a fairly important topic
that a lot of organizations struggle
with is how do you improve the quality
of the incoming code we have all this
knowledge about extreme programming for
the last 15 years at least
but like Jess was pointing out in his
keynote not a lot has changed I mean we
still see the same set of hands go up
and I was honestly to be I was honestly
surprised so many hands went up my
experience in the industry is like half
of the people were lying it is it's far
from that and so this is based on a few
you know really popular startups that
have been involved recently at least in
the last four five years and I every
startup you go and you look at the state
of affairs there and you know like you
know this is taking us 20 years back but
that's just the reality of how things
are this is the reality of how things
are and so what do we do with this
reality how do we make progress and how
do we get people to look at some of the
things that are important from a code
quality point of view and also time for
us to introspect and see are we getting
too dogmatic as a community that you
know you should do this this this this
this maybe some of those things are not
relevant anymore right and I'm going to
talk about test-driven development
particularly and and my experience of
not having done test-driven development
for at least the last since 2013 so it's
been a while and and some of the thought
processes around why why that but more
importantly right why do we care about
code quality coming back into the topic
and just setting the context right why
do we care about code quality the reason
I'm asking this question is when you go
in and you see organizations which are
very successful then you ask yourself
you know is your understanding of code
quality itself flawed or is there
something going on here that you you
know
that is just very superficial and these
guys are gonna burn down and crack so
you kind of keep asking yourself these
introspective questions and so I asked
myself like why do I care about code
quality I care about code quality
because you know none of us want you
know expensive disasters to happen in
your software if you're if your software
is accepting payments you don't want to
be basically taking people's money and
then losing that money right you don't
want to have bad things happen to you so
this is one of the fears which basically
drives people to to kind of build high
quality software there are things around
you know delays delays because of you
know having issues in your software and
not being able to put it out there on
time and that causing people who are
expecting certain things to be released
not being available stress and burnout
is another issue because if you have
lack of quality then generally you see
people are kind of always in this
firefighting mode and trying to deal
with issues all the time and you know
nobody likes to be in that situation so
you want to avoid some of these issues
and it does cause a lot of frustration
on the user's if the software does not
work the way they expect it to work
right so you want to avoid some of this
and this leads to kind of erosion of
trust in people when when the software
doesn't do what it's expected to do and
you start losing your credibility as
someone building the software so and
there may be lot more reasons but
generally these are kind of some of the
important reasons why companies really
care about quality of code and whenever
you're in doubt I would encourage you to
go back to these first principles and
say okay in this company you know is any
one of these issues that we are dealing
with right we may see the code quality
is really bad and it may not be up to
the standards that we expect but how is
that actually visible is it one of these
things that is actually coming out you
know how is it visible a lot of times
I'm sure you are familiar with these the
ice cream cone problem right the ice
cream cone testing problem
so this is basically if you map out you
know the number of tests the percentage
vise in in your in your product you know
a lot of times you find very little unit
tests a whole bunch of integration tests
and a very heavy focus on things like
selenium or a PM or one of these
automation testing frameworks and then a
whole bunch of manual checking on top of
that alright so this is this is referred
to as the ice cream cone problem and
I'll come come to you know is this bad
and how do we deal with this and things
like that but you know the the problems
that we often find that I talked about
leads to us having to typically approach
these problems in certain ways so I'm
sure everyone has faced some of these
problems that I talked earlier yes
anyone who doesn't face these problems
probably you should be speaking here
right so what is the typical approach
one would take when you see one of those
problems right delays bugs you know
frustration people being stressed out
what what do you how do you deal with
those issues in your company I want this
to be interactive so I know I'm not
talking to walls how do you deal with
some of these issues what are the
typical approaches you've used yeah so
we introduced lot more quality gates a
lot more checks lot more processes in
place to basically make sure that bad
things don't get out of control
all right automation and quality gates
okay that's a good one so you kind of
share axel get get users to give your
developers to see actual users pain and
experience that pain yes yep get to feel
the customer experience sometimes
dogfooding right people you know
encourage dogfooding use your own
products if you can use it other people
can use it anything else
so trying to create a culture and the
company where quality is emphasized and
you know you you know it becomes kind of
a key selling feature as you said that's
cool yeah
so you put a picture of your parents on
your desk and then you ask developers
that before you say ready for tests you
know what it is would you show it to
your mom that's good what I I see is
people do things like these right send
all your developers to a two day
training on how to write better quality
code yes and what do you see after that
if at all there's a difference it's not
a sustainable thing yeah it's it's great
it works for calculator problems but
doesn't work in our context yeah yeah
this I entire in soup yeah you come
excited from a training and now you want
to try all those things because it's
what is referred to as RDD as you may
driven development right okay so that's
that's another interesting technique I'm
going to touch upon that we tried that
didn't really work very well we
emphasize that people have to write unit
tests and they have to have certain
amount of code coverage without which
your your code will not get accepted
someone in the management decides that I
think 80 is a good percentage right we
don't know what it actually means but 80
sounds like a reasonable number so let's
just force it down 80% code coverage are
there is no appraisal to this time and
how does that work it works beautifully
you get 90 percent code coverage you
delete the tests or you delete the code
you run the tests everything still works
it's like wow why is there no assert
statements
right or if there are certain assert
through equals true all your making sure
is no exceptions are thrown but we know
how to deal with that try-catch around
the test and boom there it goes right so
wherever people try and force these
things down and we've all done this in
our own individual capacities at various
points and we've seen that it's actually
not had much of an impact yeah then we
say ah code reviews right let's let's
mandate code reviews in the organization
let's get every junior developer who
writes crappy code to be reviewed by
senior developers but senior developers
also write crappy code let's hire
someone who can review everybody's code
and make sure that we get great code
quality and then often they're just
debating about you know spur anthesis
should be on this line and you know the
curly braces should be here and stuff
like that I mean there is limited
success with code call a code reviews
but often you know the the ROI is
questionable I don't know about your
experience but that's kind of been my
experience not to say that these things
are bad I'm just trying to highlight
that while these things are good in
reality you know a lot of times we
struggle with some of these things the
one other thing that I think a lot of
people in the XP community will talk
about is pair programming so let's watch
this old video of me and JB Rimes Berg
how many people here know JB few people
yeah one of the you know very strong
founders of you know this trying to
basically not founders but trying to
make XP really popular one of the
Guardian pasca Ward winner by the agile
Alliance for let's quickly see this
smooth binary that's some of the finer
and this is the which multitask
yeah so what are we talking here that's
small the binary I think yeah anyway
that was just a fun video we did in 2010
conference that we were trying to show
like how what's what are typical ways
you see people pair programming in in
organizations it's literally one person
working the other person dozing off most
often or it's used as a way to train
somebody on the job
and things like that which are not
necessarily bad things but they don't
solve the code quality issue right away
and something to be aware the other
common issue is that people start
ramping up the testing team right I
don't know if you've seen this but you
often find that whenever you have code
quality issues the typical answer is
let's hire more testers so now I'm going
to address your code quality issue but
it's going to stop bad things going out
of the door but it stops anything going
out of the door
people try things like sonar sonar lint
you know serious other static code
analysis tools they try and integrate it
with it and and some of these are kind
of again quite useful but have their own
problem so I want to quickly touch upon
some challenges that we face feel with
this one of the big
lenses that we typically run is these
initiatives end up being pretty in
isolation so they don't actually help
much they end up just being in isolation
and don't create a culture around this
so they just stay in pockets but your
overall code quality is still kind of
bad people live in age of instant
gratification where if they do something
they want instant gratification and the
challenge with with some of these things
that we were talking pair programming
unit testing test driven development
etcetera etcetera is you need to invest
it takes at least six months or
sometimes a year before you can actually
see real advantage right there's any one
implemented TDD and seen the benefit
like next week one person okay it's
usually a much longer journey in terms
of actually getting some of the benefits
out of it a lot of times you have tools
have put sonar cube here but there could
be any other tool that overwhelm you
with all kinds of feedback and so much
non actionable data that you don't know
what to do about and people just start
ignoring like we ignore traffic lights
right it's just too overwhelming for
people to deal with some of these things
often these are like all-or-nothing kind
of a thing like you need to do all of
this or you get nothing
and to me this is a non-starter this is
not a great way to approach this so I'm
going to look at some possible
alternatives again not suggesting that
this is a silver bullet and this will
work for everyone some things that we've
tried and have had some successes with
this but before that I think we should
talk about the most important part of
this presentation which is to talk about
me right so my name is Naresh I live in
Mumbai don't act in Bollywood yet I
started a long back with the company
called thought works which is where I
kind of got exposure to all these cool
techniques of extreme programming and
you know we did some really great work
learning extreme programming practices
and stuff like that scrum was considered
a bad name bad word and it's still then
I was part of this company called act I
wear wear again is one of these places
where I went from thought
works thinking like code quality see ICD
these are the these are the standard way
of doing things version control like who
would you would question some of these
things and then you show up at this
company and you're like what but they
are amazingly successful so you ask
yourself like what's wrong right is
something wrong with me or with them and
and same thing and then I went to be a
partner at industrial logic that we
built eLearning
thought of a lot of people at Google at
Amazon and a bunch of other companies
how to write good quality code and stuff
like that started my own startup
frustrated with trying to help people
developers especially improve it's just
better to focus on kids they listen
right so I I started a company called
adventure labs where we would build
games for kids to learn mental
arithmetic then work out well I spend a
lot of money
crashed burnt dead I continued to run
conferences and that's that's kind of
where my passion for building a platform
convention that we use so I happen to be
one of the developer on this project and
right now the only developer on this
project but confident is actually
something started in 2012 so it's been
going on for a while we've done about
two million dollars worth of ticket
sales through this it's a it's not a pet
project that's it's beyond the pet
project status we have about 100,000
users actively using it and we have zero
automated tests so I'll talk about that
a little bit later in the in the in this
talk but then I went and joined this
company called hike messenger where I
was a you know consultant trying to help
them and again one of those moments
where this is the fastest unicorn but
some of the code quality things are are
pretty bad and you know like stating and
thinking how could this possibly be
working at 100 million users care when
the code quality is so bad so again you
go back to this question that is there
something wrong with them or something
wrong with you anyway these days I run a
consulting company and of helping a
large investment bank with their data
strategy so that's
a little bit about me but let's come
back to some possible alternatives and
hopefully this helps you understand why
I'm probably qualified a little bit to
talk about some of the topics that I'll
be talking about so what are some of the
alternatives one of the things we saw is
that when you put sonar and you have
some interesting you know data that is
coming out of the sonar nobody goes and
looks at sonar
so the first hack that we tried is what
if sonar could post these feedback on
your pull requests the moment someone
creates a pull request
what if sonar could put some of this
feedback on the pull request so the
person who's going to merge or approve
the PR is at least gonna look at it
saying what's all this noise on this
page right and so the first thing we did
was basically did a quick hack using PR
builder so PR builder watches whenever
there is a new pull request that comes
in you basically look at the pull
requests you run it against you know a
sonar instance that you have takes the
comments from sonar and puts it as
comments on the PR itself so instead of
asking people to go and look at
different places bring that feedback
into the pull request itself and what we
saw is you know people complained a lot
that this sonar thing is nonsense like
why is this a problem why is that a
problem what does this even mean
right like why is this not stopping me -
why is this stopping me to merge the
code and that was a great starting point
because people now started at least
taking interest in understanding what
this thing even means right and we went
through a lot of refinement Aaron was
there Aaron and remembers we did we did
a lot of refinements to basically come
up with the minimalistic set of rules in
sonar that we thought were absolutely
necessary that the code any new coming
Court should should meet and it would
only check on the Delta code not on
everything
right so if there are changes that are
made it would only assert the only would
verify the quality of that and so what
we saw is you know it would produce
things like this and then we would say
if there are critical issues then you
won't be able to merge the
which came as a is a bit of a top-down
kind of a push but at least got people
to start paying attention did this
improve the quality of the court not
really right but what this did is make
started making people little aware of
some of these concepts that we were
trying to talk about make it a little
bit more practical and contextual in
what they are trying to do day to day
instead of running a theoretical class
on static code analysis this is what
psychometric complexity means this is
what this means I mean it's it's more of
a pull based approach rather than a push
based approach once we did this one of
the things we realized is you know we
could actually do something slightly
better than this because the challenge
we had is people who were merging the
pull request didn't really see what was
the impact or didn't know what was the
impact of this pull request if they
merge this code so we wanted to give
them some kind of some kind of a measure
or a sense of how risky this pull
request is that you're trying to merge
because again
remember what we're trying to do is stop
bad things from coming into the main
trunk so you know what kind of tools how
can we enable people to make those
decisions better so the next step we
tried was what we call as the PR risk
advisor PR risk advisor is essentially
any time a pull request is created it
will look at all historical data and it
will give you a report like this saying
you know this is what the pull request
is about this is the files that have
been changed in this pull request this
is the number of lines in this file this
is the churn as in how many times this
file has changed recently here are the
number of bugs that this file has been
committed in the recent times when
whenever a bug was fixed this particular
file was involved in those bug fixes
like that this file had changed then we
did this it would have things like what
is the sacrum attic complexity
percentage of duplication again all of
this information just pulled out of Sona
some information that is there with
whatever project management tool that
you're using so you know and we had a
convention that anytime you are checking
in in any time you are making a commit
or raising a pull request
you put the the ticket ID in it so we
could see if this is a bug this is a new
feature and we could have some
intelligence like that so what this did
is this actually helped us help the
reviewers who were reviewing the court
make a lot more informed decisions and
at this point people started paying a
lot more attention to some of the things
in sonar that it was giving in terms of
static code analysis all right
still no test still none of that stuff
is just very basic and of starting with
making people aware of the code quality
and helping people who are reviewing the
court to make more informed decisions
clear so far the next thing was a big
influence from this particular talk at
at the functional programming conference
and I happen to be wearing the t-shirt
today was by Aaron who was who's a
professor and a PhD student in Indiana
University and he talked about design
patterns versus anti-pattern in APL how
many people have heard of this
programming language APL it stands for a
programming language which tells you how
old and outdated this languages but it's
still one of the most fascinating
language out there it was originally
created two by Jacob Iverson to create
to help mathematicians you know
represent mathematical notations and so
the language has been around for 50-plus
years the reason I'm bringing this up is
these guys have been living under the
rock and they've been doing some very
fascinating things everything that we
consider as best practices these
consider these guys considered as an
anti-pattern and this is something
really fascinating that's happening and
I kind of drew a lot of inspiration from
this talk and try to bring in some of
these techniques back at work so for
example one of the things they talk
about is abstractions are considered
humble we consider a lot of things that
we have done over the years in terms of
abstraction is very important
but these guys considered abstraction
very it's an abstraction considered
harmful and one of the things they talk
about is if you can make your things you
know lot more transparent rather than
abstract lot more visible then it's that
much more easier to understand what's
going on otherwise a lot of times in
name of abstraction we just jump through
hoops and hoops hoops and hoops before
we understand what's going on
the other interesting thing that they
talk about is basically what else can I
talk about this this is a whole bunch of
interesting thing but yeah one of the
things they talk about is libraries
considered harmful especially black box
libraries considered harmful and that
the thought process is that if you if
you're gonna have these black box
libraries you don't know what's going on
inside that and if you if you're gonna
use some of these things then you don't
know what impact is going to create on
your software one other thing that they
considered harmful and this language has
right now it has if statements and
control structures but generally any a
player a peeler wouldn't write code with
if or switch or any of these things you
know the way they write code is is very
interesting like you write code as if
there are no conditional logic in your
code and the way they achieve that is by
turning that into a data structure and
so you then just basically take the data
structure and you do data structure
manipulation to give you an example
you've all looked at the schedule in
convention right the multi-track version
of it right now imagine as a programmer
if you're building something like this
the way you would typically do is you
would have a list of sessions in the
database sorted by time so you would get
the list of sessions sorted by time and
sorted by track and then you would have
a big for loop and then you really trade
over the for loop you will take each
section of that list and you will check
what type of a session it is oh it's a
keynote which means it needs to be shown
across all the four tracks right it's a
90-minute workshop which means it needs
to span across multiple sessions right
things like that so you'd have a big
four for loop and a bunch of conditional
logic inside it for each of the special
conditions that you want to handle these
things
right someone in APL would look at that
code and just delete it yeah because you
don't write code like that instead what
they would do is they would write these
small functions each function would
basically be like five characters long
and then they would basically say that
if this is this what should happen to
this
so essentially you get the data from the
database convert it into a
two-dimensional matrix and then you
apply so you have a data which is a
linear list you have a list of functions
which needs to be applied and you do a
matrix multiplication on that and it
spits out a two-dimensional you know
schedule out and it's fascinating to
just see that if there's no if
conditions there's no you know none of
that it's just a matrix multiplication
so we started applying some of these
techniques in the way we were writing
code as a way to kind of help people
improve and simplify code I think what
I'm trying to talk about us we get
carried away too much with all the
design patterns and all of the fancy
stuff but sometimes when you look at
these old languages and draw inspiration
from them they have a very different and
a very simplistic way of writing code
which I think can really help improve
the quality of the code all right all
this is fine people say you know this is
all great if I'm writing new code I can
I can put in a lot of these checks and
stuff like that but the real problem is
you know we have to deal with legacy
code we have stuff that has been written
you know yesterday and it's legacy
nobody wants to touch that and people
fear of touching that why do people fear
touching that this we don't understand
enough about it there are no tests we
don't know if we change something what
will break you know all of those kind of
typical challenges so what do you do
when you have legacy code where do you
start this is kind of like we've been
trying to solve these problem for 20
years but every company you go into and
you say okay you have legacy problem but
where would you start
and sometimes consultants go in and say
oh just let's take six months out and
we're going to refactor all your court
and then we'll be good right we will
have a team of people writing tests we
will have a
of people refactoring your code and at
the end of it everything will magically
come together and life will be great
after that never seen that work
unfortunately
so what we do is this there's an
open-source tool that I had built quite
a few years ago it's called c3 what it
does it helps you visualize the quality
of your code so let me just take a
minute and explain what this complicated
graph looks like so this is a tree map
what this tree map is doing is those you
see these boxes each of those big boxes
is kind of a package or a folder inside
your code base so this is a fairly large
code base and then each of these black
lines is basically representing a file
so if you see a big box that means that
whole folder is fairly big inside that
this particular file is relatively much
larger in size as compared to the
smaller file so it gives you a tree
visualization a hierarchical view of
what your code bases and then it uses
color as a way to signify what is your
c3 score and the way we calculate the c3
score is we look at what is the
complexity of this core which is
cyclomatic complexity linear parts
through your code right if you have a if
else in your code then your cyclomatic
complexity is two there are two linear
parts through your code if you have more
conditions than the cyclomatic
complexity is higher there are a lot of
studies that show the higher your
cyclomatic complexity the more likely
people are you know going to make
mistakes in that code because it's
harder to understand then the next
parameter it looks at is your code
coverage which is essentially what is
the code coverage on this court and most
often with legacy code the code coverage
is zero are very minimalistic and the
third parameter it looks at is churn how
many times this particular file has been
changed in the last 30 days right so it
takes those three parameters put them
together and there's a weighted average
of those three to give you a
visualization so whatever you see as big
red things are problem areas but the
biggest red spot in that
is probably the you know the hot spot in
your application that you know there may
be like these two three piles that
everybody touches on a daily basis has
very high complexity has very low
coverage right so that is the place
where I would want to start investing
some time and addressing those issues
rather than saying oh you know this file
doesn't have code coverage so I'm gonna
go and write some tests against it right
so this is kind of trying to make it a
little bit more pragmatic for people to
approach this and trying to simplify
saying you know if you want to figure
out what are the hot spots in your
application you run ce3 through it it
will basically give you a visualization
and as you make improvements in your
code you can see if actually you are
reducing some of those hot spots or not
as new code comes in you want to see how
this graph is evolving over a period of
time so this seemed to be a very kind of
a handy tool for me at least to kind of
visualize the code quality and start you
know having discussions with people
saying how can we improve the code
quality of this the other tool that we
used which was kind of very helpful I
don't know if people have attended who
needs talk when it was here a couple of
years ago he's the author of this tool
called defeat this was built at Twitter
when essentially what they were trying
to do is when Twitter was trying to move
from their rails back-end to a more mono
layer from a monolithic to a
microservices kind of an architecture
they wanted some way to know that as
they break these services into micro
services they are not you know breaking
the contract and they're not making that
the results are not coming out
differently so one of the interesting
things this did is is to compare what
the old code gives you what the old API
gives you versus what the new API gives
you so what they do is they take the
traffic that's coming the live traffic
that's coming they basically fork the
traffic they send it through this new
instance that you have an old instance
that you have you get the response back
and then you compare the two instances
and you see what is the difference so as
you build your micro services without
actually writing any tests you now have
a way to validate what's the difference
between that but when they started doing
that one of the problems they found is
that it
give you a lot of false negative which
means you know IDs could be different or
time stamps could be different you know
slightly different and that would start
failing the test saying hey something is
different so how do you deal with that
that's kind of where Diffie comes into
action is what they do is they they set
up three instances so this is the
candidate instance which is essentially
the new instance a new microservice
instance or new API instance a primary
and secondary are the existing you know
old code and then you take the
difference between these two guys and
you get non-deterministic differences
and then you take the difference between
these two and you get the raw
differences then you again take the
difference between these two to
eliminate any non-deterministic you know
non basically noise out of it and
they've done some very interesting stuff
they use a bit of machine learning to
kind of figure out what is deterministic
non-deterministic what should be
important what should not be important
and this is something that we kind of
also heavily used especially when in the
legacy code when people start making
changes without them having to write
tests you would run these defeat things
and then you would get differences and
then you would kind of show them
visualize like what is the difference
between these two instances and
eventually we hooked it up with CI and
stuff like that so that every time
someone checks in they get that kind of
a feedback but originally it was just as
a pilot we would run this in this side
and see if you know as you are basically
making changes to your services are you
breaking backward compatibility or not
now again the limitation of this is this
works well for services back-end stuff
not necessarily for UI
I know Puneet is working on some ideas
to to make this extensible for UI as
well but this is a again a pretty
interesting tool that we have so quickly
going to pause I have spoken at a length
about a bunch of different ideas that we
tried so the first idea just to recap we
try to take whatever feedback was there
and pull that back into into your PR
itself so people can see that and kind
of start at least be curious about it
help give information to the reviewers
from a PR risk Assessor to kind of help
them understand how
they can improve when they're basically
reviewing court if there are if it's a
high-risk than at least they would
probably check out the cord locally and
then run it locally and see what's going
on so that kind of helped improve the
quality of the incoming code after that
I talked about you know some influence
from APL and array oriented programming
in terms of focus on simplicity and
trying to help people simplify things
not focus so much on TDD or classroom
trainings or things like that but more
practical stuff that people can
appreciate then I talked about that all
that is great but if you have legacy
code then what do you do so I talked
about c3 as a way to visualize what are
your hotspots and kind of use that as a
way to drive some of these changes I
talked about differ which is something
that we used in the back end to kind of
visualize what are the as people are
making changes are they breaking things
again this is all without trying to
invest a lot of effort and writing test
Suites and things like that this is kind
of almost getting at least for API
scaring testing for free so far with me
yep I talked about coming back to this
testing pyramid and this is something
that I used to show quite often in terms
of the the different types of tests that
we would put in into a system and what I
realized this while this is great how do
you start with this right like you want
to have this kind of a test pyramid in
your organization but where do you start
with this because developers are busy
and they're not interested in this so
where do you go one of the things that
actually work very well for us is we had
a team of our automation engineers who
were very enthusiastic and kind of felt
like they were second-class citizens in
the organization do other people have
the same experience yeah so what we did
is we said okay there are these guys
look good with automation they care
about quality they really like some of
these things so how about we actually
work with them help them learn some of
these techniques so they can actually go
in the code and start putting in some of
these tests you know themselves
actually having the developers to come
in because again you know unless you see
the value in your context you won't be
convinced and trying to convince
developers to you know invest in some of
these things is much harder as as
opposed to you know working with
automation engineers who are already
kind of invested in this and it's easier
to kind of help them and also they feel
like they're learning new skills and
they're growing in in terms of their
career so that actually became a nice
book for us so me our own a bunch of
other people started working with the
with the automation engineers and kind
of helping them understand how they
could write component tests how they
could write you know integration tests
how they could write other kinds of
tests and then kind of check that code
back into the same repo right not into a
different place but check that code back
into the same repo this is one of the
examples I'm running short of time but
this is one of the examples where I
explain the different levels in how we
went about doing that this is a this is
something again that has been existed a
long time back from a long time I mean I
remember this slide is from 2003 one of
my slides from 2003 and this this used
to work really well back in the days but
now you know trying to get this kind of
a commitment from people is much much
more harder so we kind of hijacked this
and we we just started getting the
automation engineers to kind of help us
put some of these things in place in in
retrospect not not from the from the
before and once we started doing this
for for about three months
then developers started taking interest
in some of these things they started
seeing that how this actually helps and
then there was some interest in the
organization I wouldn't I wouldn't stand
here and lie saying Oh everybody in the
organization was doing that it was not
only few people took interest and then
that started coming in but I think I was
happy because you know at least you get
some momentum going you can't get
everybody on board but you can get some
people to start doing some of these
things one thing that actually worked
really well is this whole discussion
that on acceptance criteria and that was
something that we saw was growing lot
more and I saw I would say that that's
something that I would also encourage
all of you to kind of push back into
your organization saying before you
start
building on something focus on
acceptance criteria and that will help
again improve the quality of the
incoming code because some of the
assumptions will get caught at this
state standard slide on how we do
continuous integration gonna skip some
of this because I think I would jump to
questions so I know it's a little rushed
but I want to take some time for
questions I just talked about a few
ideas that might be useful for you to
consider as you're trying to help
influence this is trying to say that you
know don't go Big Bang in terms of you
know getting everyone to do trainings
and then expect magic to happen because
that never works instead look at some of
these simpler smaller starting points to
create this culture where people start
caring about quality and start caring
about simplicity in the code and that
can be a much better starting point for
improving the quality of the incoming
code all right
with that we have five minutes for
questions yeah so your last couple of
flights kind of touched my topic but I
still want to ask how to incentivize a
developer to do unit testing how do i
incentivize the developers to do unit
tests what is the real value in your
addressed deeply you kind of just check
every path probably at a function level
so every line of code is getting
authenticated so probably you may not
you may handle all the errors and areas
at a unit level not expecting your
system level to handle all you okay so
it's getting much more pinpointed
feedback at the at the source rather
than you know a permutation of different
combinations coming at that at the top
level so you know you think that's the
real value of unit test and do the
developers really care about that
we saw your pyramid probably the biggest
return that you could get for the time
that you've invested because we find I
mean
if developers would see it that way
maybe that's one way of so if the
developers saw that it will help them
with feedback and it will improve that
then they would they would be interested
but that the cats are their entire
outcome not talking only about their
program but compared to the entire out
yeah but the catch there is developers
writing good unit tests right because
you could write unit tests but you not
get that kind of a feedback right so how
do you incentivize developers to write
good unit tests and that's a hard
problem in my opinion I spent 10 15
years trying to do that and I gave up I
think it's it's it's hard to get
developers to incentivize right not that
I'm not saying that it's it's wrong we
should not be doing that but I'm just
saying it's a much harder problem to do
that right so instead what I'm
suggesting is you don't start with unit
tests you start with some of these other
peripheral things that will help people
get a feel for what it means to get
quicker feedback may not be through unit
tests but maybe through some other
mechanism static code analysis PR risk
Assessor or other kinds of things and
then that you may start addicting them
to this habit of getting some kind of a
feedback every time they check in stuff
and then you can say hey you can do
something better by doing this in the
code but then there is this whole
contrasting thing that's going on in the
industry that we also should be aware of
right Fred George talks about this so
when they started doing micro services
at at internet was that forward Internet
company they bear their micro services
were not more than hundred lines of code
and you know if you can't write hundred
lines of code without making a mistake
then there's a problem but also more
importantly the way you build the system
is it's resilient even if you make
mistakes it's okay you can deal with it
so sometimes you know the way you
architects things and stuff like that
you may say well you don't really need
that much of a pinpointed feedback and
you can deal without that
at least to kind of stock this this
whole notion so there is yeah there is
the different kind of a thought process
yeah big question on beefy so once the
server goes down so whatever we are
seeing there difference right we are not
able to see in anywhere so doing any log
for that when a server goes down like
one of the de fee no idea where the
candidate is running basically okay so
you have the candidate you have two
other the primary and secondary one of
those kind of go down yeah where there's
a basically de fees running that's where
we deployed that the fees are right if
it is goes down it is heading down so we
are not able to see the differences in
the UI
whatever you show that HTTP something
right correct so if it goes down you
you're not gonna see so I'm not sure
like what you always is it is it
possible to say that long or somewhere
sir oh so it does output whatever is
going on as a log you can actually suck
out a log on in life life basis so one
of the things we did is in our CI we
would actually keep looking at that and
if it went down will basically pause the
test bring up Diffie again but sometimes
it does go down and then you run it
again
so yeah you do have some of those
problems they have a hosted solution now
where they put all of these things in
place all right I'm out of time I will
be around so I'll happy to take more
questions outside and happy to talk
about why I don't write tests anymore so
we didn't get into that topic but happy
to take some of those questions thank
you
[Applause]